hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong on the equity
derivatives
and right now guys i do youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you guys how i actually do
my threads
you know the different tools that i use
that are working for me that are
deficient
and i know that a lot of stuff that i
can find on the internet is basically
people repeating stuff but not properly
so they don't give you the full
information they're not using those
techniques i
use them i know what is working uh i
mean what is working for me
the way i do it you know a technique can
work for someone and not for someone
else because he's just gonna do
something slightly different
so guys if you want to know about all
the stuff you are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on
clvs
let's get into it
[Music]
so i know that a lot of you uh don't
feel good right now
you know because you are along the staff
i don't know where you bought it
but you don't feel good because it's
just
bleeding it's treading lower but look at
this beautiful green
hour guys this is my view and i'm just
gonna you know
try to tell you that everything is fine
you should not panic
the price is going lower i mean right
now we reached level
below which things are gonna start
to not be good we still have an ultimate
support level at 450
but first let me come back to what
happened here so the first thing is the
breakout that occurred
here so how do i find this breakout as
usual guys
trend lines all right i'm on the
logarithmic scale and i
find the two recent highs that were you
know
doing this uh downtrend so this one and
this one
and i connect them i'm not connecting
this one because
actually those two are the most
important ones because they are the most
recent in time
and then i can see that here i'm
connecting as well this
and i'm connecting as well you know
almost
almost this one so this trend line is
the correct one
you can see some trend lines like this
they're not too bad as well because it's
using this one you know you can do a
trend line like this
but then you need to go here and then it
gives you a bit more room so
you know it all depends how you do but
my trend line is like this
because it connects due to recent highs
here and i think this is the most
important thing
then you can find as well some support
levels
at this level so same thing guys
the most recent the data is the best
it is it's going to work because most
people are going to use it
so here you know even for me it's a
struggle you know i never know
but you can put it here all right
because here i have a high and here i
have a high
but then you are above this whole
consolidation level that
occurred just before the breakout and
then it would already you know
be broken on the downside so i think
that
the best way to use this one is actually
to put it lower so you capture
all this whole consolidation here
and you have this level as well and here
you have two kind of
fake breakouts it's not perfect
it's not very precise but it's giving us
some
areas so the area is that we have here a
double indicator
you know we have this downward sloping
trendline that was resistance and became
support
and we have this uh horizontal trendline
that is support as well the level is 550
guys
so below 550 i mean below 5
30 i would start to worry for the short
term
and i would check the news i checked the
news i didn't see anything
once again it's a pharmaceutical firm so
they can have any
you know very important news coming up
uh
you know just like this so careful on
this
and uh here what i see guys is that
we're still you know just doing this
whole breakout of this very long-term
trend
and that we are just retesting it so we
broke the moving averages that's not
good all right let's be honest
that's not good so the situation is not
amazing but it's not bad and here
guys it's a very nice level to buy i was
saying that around like seven eight
don't buy it here
wait for six to me six was a strong
support because this is the
breakout level so actually six was a bit
ambitious
now we're at 5 15. i'm still bullish and
to be honest i'm gonna be bullish even
above 450
so this whole area for me is gonna be an
area where we're gonna have a lot of
fighting between buyers and sellers
let's check quickly the short interest
on so
i go on market watch let's see you know
who is selling is it hedge funds or not
38
all right hedge funds are selling guys
hedge funds are selling so the short
squeeze may
can happen i want to see something else
i've gone market bit
market bid guys gives you some
information about what institutional
clients are doing
so it's first it's a nice way to compare
your short interest
short interest first thing
31 okay it's close enough 38 31
this is correct and then you go on
institutional ownership guys i like to
go there
and see who is doing what so you can see
that
institutional clients or hedge fund
asset managers they were selling
massively
uh clds in 2020 especially here so they
were selling
second quarter then they were buying it
fourth
third and fourth quarter and now they
are selling it
first quarter 2021 the seller the seller
of this so hedge funds are building
short positions they think it is
overvalued all right guys
let's see who is right because i've seen
some
overvalued stocks that went much higher
i repeat my view guys bullish definitely
because of this breakout all right
i'm doing technical analysis i'm not
doing fundamental analysis i don't care
you know what the earnings i don't care
about anything i care about the flows
the flows are very bullish here and this
is just to retest
and it it can last you know a few more
months all right
maybe june maybe i don't know but we're
going to have this crazy rally coming i
cannot guarantee but i'm very convinced
and once again because this is
the big picture for me is that we are at
the beginning of bubble all right guys
go check it out on my snp and nasdaq
technical analysis videos
where i show you guys why i think we're
on the bubble and why i think
the market is gonna take 100 to 100 in
the coming year
or two years so that's it for me i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when to upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys